we have Wesley so in the studio Wesley a
difficult game for you yesterday and
even today you are under some pressure
how do you feel yeah I'm not sure yeah
I'm not exactly sure why what I'm doing
here in this interview it seems like
they just want to ask you and test some
questions when you're down
how my day goes during all the U.S
championships I've played so far it's uh
it was a difficult game indeed
yes yeah actually I thought it was very
complicated but oh can't turn on the
engine because sure you want to see how
bad like I think if the H3 maybe G3 is
slightly better for white now I could be
wrong
okay it feels all equal yeah it's so
crazy how the computer evaluates
position these days because black has a
double pawn and uh my king side is solid
but then the computer gives all zero so
it fits insane like humanly
I think everyone would take white but
anyway after H3 Knight F4 very
interesting I didn't expect that he
would go all in with G5 G3 G4 it is
gaining some momentum
at all worried at this point how did you
assess it did you feel like you were uh
worse better neutral I mean of course I
wanted to play for win with white yeah
so I mean that's exactly my downfall
instrument like you want to try to play
for a win but then you start risking and
then you make then you start losing the
third and the players are very strong
and they but I thought I thought today I
was wasn't that badly off that's why I'm
curious to see what the engine thought
because instead of Knight G1 I think
that was the best move now if you want
the best man I think you take that Force
also equally yes
um but maybe not that easy yeah I mean
you have to go something like Knight D4
but not what you were calculating the
Knight before button even E1 G6
E5 Knight D2 yeah it should be equal
[Music]
um
for for black right yeah it depends what
they well I mean humanly again if equal
but the computer has other ideas yeah
yeah I didn't expect this G5 G4 it's
very strong Darius is playing very well
in this tournament he's also playing
very confidently but again I didn't
think I was that worth so we need I
think there was one moment uh somewhere
around this point when you got your Rook
to H1 instead of Rook H7 Queen to G4
seems to have been a very testing option
wow we bought Memphis
four ideas
and queen takes F3 oh yeah without a
limited because we I think we have
different mind but with the queen of H5
which is slightly different because it's
still not over by the way
but it just remains complicated the game
remains complicated I didn't see this
and I take E4 after Queen G4 yeah I mean
I think one can hold probably but yes if
you go back after Queen G4 King E1
there's ideas of D5 as well
seems like he's keeping some pressure in
the position can you go back on move 23
how should I look at oh after H5 on Mob
22 sure yeah I guess I thought I had
some something here but I guess it it
never works like okay I mean
black cuff why does some ideas but I
don't think they ever work like after
Rook H1 I think black only has one way
to play Oh but that computer games
okay E5 is not a human movie H4 you're
not even looking at that side
Knight F3 Queen G4 check King G2 Knight
H5
yeah and it never works on so yeah from
H4 probably Knight F4 and queen takes H4
yeah neither fourth so after Rook H1
yeah very interesting game I like okay
very interesting game absolutely I mean
if we make the mistake he could also
lose H2 Knight F1 Rook H4 yeah I guess
it's all just equal exactly yeah nothing
happened after that you guys kept it
quite uh quite tense but pretty neutral
yeah I mean queen G8 King G8 so Infinity
King G8
excuse me what like here Queen takes
King takes okay then King D2 and so
forth
yes oh yeah I mean play a few moves
Wesley still a lot of games to go five
rounds to go how do you turn this
tournament around
wait for next year
you're not harboring any uh hopes or uh
I mean I'm waiting for a victory to five
if like 33 and a half points ahead of me
how can I ever hope for a victory but
the good thing are the prices of the US
Championship have been greased compared
to because it's been the same I think
for the last five six years and I just
noticed the fear it in grief so I'd like
to thank Rex and Genie very much of
course on inflation somehow oh yeah yeah
we're starting to talk political here
considering the November elections and
this is the first year that I can vote
so there you go we have the battle
inflation somehow and Free Speech yeah
oh my goodness but um
yeah obviously things didn't start the
way I wanted it to think uh their number
of reasons um
but I think also in between this
tournament and the chess 960 there was
only a space of 12 Days really and I
just didn't pay enough serious attention
to this tournament I didn't have much
time to upload some online tournaments
played like a lot of Blitz Games and it
just
I knew this tournament was going to be
hard I think the U.S Championship is
probably the hardest tournament I play
every single year because uh everyone is
it huh why is it the hardest in your
opinion uh because because you play a
lot of elite events right against 27 50
plus yeah
it's hard I mean this is my eighth
year's championship I believe or seven I
think eight but it's basically a mixture
of top players like Fabi and then you
have all the young up and coming guys
the kids
then you have a very experienced very
strong players you know like used to be
a scorpion but he doesn't play anymore
on his truck but gather comskey but now
you have like elshon Harry Robson uh
Sam Fabian I mean these guys are low
rated than us but on a very good day on
a good day they couldn't beat anybody in
the world and the basically in order not
to lose his rating you have to score at
least plus three or plus four
for guys like me and right now I'm on
minus one so I'm obviously losing a
bunch and
everyone is well prepared here I think
American players in general are very
booked up in comparison to Asian players
or other different players and
they all play for a win I mean I also
want to play for win myself but then can
backfire
easily so
and if you look at the history I
basically lose an average of like 12
breaking points the U.S championship
year after year so I think live on it I
have made our annual rating uh
contribution awesome Wesley thank you
very much uh for all these insights
we'll see you tomorrow yeah be back
tomorrow for more torture
thank you very welcome thank you Wesley
we look forward to the torture yes
indeed we have